depuis des jours les italiens tentent de
briser l'isolément imposé par la
quarantaine en chantant à l'unisson
depuis leur balcon
les instants de complicité qui se
multiplient avec parfois des accents
bien de chez nous
[Musique]
oh
des gestes de solidarité qui s'exprime
aussi en silence
ces moments entre voisins sont pour
certains l'occasion de se dégourdir en
prenant un peu d'air de souligner un
anniversaire
ou de se désennuyer de façon ludique
mais dans tous les cas l'objectif est de
socialiser
malgré les mesures de confinement à
respecter ici au pays
la chanteuse florence k est allé
surprendre sa grand-mère en isolement en
compagnie d'une chorale improvisée
[Musique]
autres scènes émouvantes
cette fois en espagne samedi soir
quelques minutes après que le premier
ministre est annoncé des mesures de
confinement des milliers de personnes
sont spontanément sortis sur leur balcon
pour rendre hommage au personnel médical
ces infirmières docteur est préposée qui
sont devenus malgré eux les véritables
héros de cette crise ici julie aimant
radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]